después empiezan a
y tiene pasado está platicando así en
agosto con alguien sigue practicando que
normal y de repente
es lo que te lleva a decir quién ha
pasado
porque dices voy a guardar esto justo
aquí para que nunca se me olvide y jamás
lo vuelves a encontrar a quien le ha
pasado o dices esta contraseña nunca se
me va a olvidar así que la voy a poner
el día siguiente se te olvida a quien le
ha pasado o cuando sacas el boleto de
estacionamiento y de pronto
desaparece de tu existencia y no lo
vuelves a ver quién le ha pasado alguna
vez o cuántas veces has olvidado el
nombre de la persona que acabas de
conocer
y qué dices me acuerdo de cara pero no
de tu nombre nunca decimos algo
contrario verdad me acuerdo de tu nombre
pero no de tu cara no eso nunca pase no
se preocupen su cerebro no está roto en
su memoria funciona perfectamente y mi
objetivo el día de hoy es probarles que
todos aquí presentes ya tienen una
memoria excepcional y que funciona todos
los días y si prestan atención al cien
por ciento en los próximos minutos lo
van a comprobar pero necesito de su
total presencia quien está presente
perfecto mientras tanto los invito a
imaginar lo siguiente en este momento
todo este lugar véanlo
se va a transformar en su memoria y
vamos a comenzar a crear una serie de
recuerdos en ella yo los voy a acompañar
así que desde este momento todos van a
ver directamente hacia la puerta de
entrada vean directamente allá ahí van a
imaginar cómo sale un tiro al blanco muy
grande para que le lancen una flecha
listo ahora vean al centro del salón ahí
van a ver cómo sale un cerebro muy
grande que se está encendiendo
listo ver a los arcos del fondo ahí van
a ver cómo sale una goma con manos y
pies que está borrando todo el lugar
ahora vean a la pantalla y la pantalla
va a salir una lupa que los está mirando
fijamente a los ojos
ahora vean a las luces de arriba y aquí
va a caer un diario para que comiencen a
escribir en el ahora ven a las letras de
télex y van a imaginar cómo empieza a
escurrir el pegamento y ese pegamento
comienza a pegarse en ustedes y por
último aquí en el escenario van a ver a
un cuerpo humano un aspecto muy gracioso
y extraño a la vez listo manténgalo
presente
hace muchos años no muchos años
tuve la fortuna de terminar una muy
valiosa carrera universitaria de la cual
no me acuerdo de nada de lo que aprendí
esto es lo que se supone que debo
recordar después de terminar la
universidad en 60 materias para ser
competente en un mundo laboral y cuando
termine esto es lo que acabé recordando
absurdo e imagínate estudiar una carrera
completa y sólo recordar el 5% de lo que
aprendiste o tres materias yo creía que
tiene una clase de problema es decir era
algún experto eso ha sido un experto
sacando diez sedes pasando materias
acabando semestres pero era todo un
maestro olvidando las cosas y no sólo
eso sino que parecía que mi memoria me
hacía demasiado bullying y se burlaba
vez se burlaba de mí les decían cosas
como hoy y parece que toda esta
información en tu cerebro ya no es útil
así que todo lo voy a borrar por ti sin
olvidar las cosas y no sólo eso no sé
nunca supe por qué se olvidaban cosas
tan irrelevantes o importantes el
contrario recordaba con años de
distancia muchas cosas pero sin
olvidaban cosas tan simples como qué es
lo que iba a ser cuando abra la puerta
del refrigerador en donde dejó las
llaves cuando las traigo en la mano
incluso en donde estación el coche
cuando me doy cuenta que no traía coche
y en verdad creía que mi memoria era un
problema todos los días hasta que un día
sucedió lo extraordinario recibió una
llamada de una persona que no me
acordaba de su nombre por supuesto
invitando con una conferencia y me decía
yo sé que a ti te gustaría tener una
mejor memoria así que deberías de ir yo
a poco es existe okey déjamelo a punto
para que no se me olvide
afortunadamente no se me olvidó ir yendo
y cuando entré al salón de la
conferencia había miles de personas
emocionadas y todas
y yo qué clase de lugar es este que hago
aquí cuando de pronto así sale en el
escenario un tipo que empezó a hacer
algo que en mi vida había visto jamás
jamás el llamado bicampeón mundial de
memoria y un poco ese existe
increíble y empiezo a hacer lo imposible
es decir empezó a memorizar sería
recordar todos los nombres que tenía
enfrente de todas las personas que eran
decenas y después le dieron un número de
50 dígitos y se lo recordó todo al
derecho y al revés yo ni siquiera me
sabían mi número de teléfono
y después le dieron un libro de más de
500 hojas y se lo sabía todo de memoria
sin esforzarse
este sujeto o está loco o debe ser el
nuevo dios de nuestros tiempos tengo que
conocer lo justo ahora entonces me fui
para atrás lo empecé a cazar y cuando se
bajó del escenario dije justo ahora si
no no va a ser nunca y comencé a correr
a lo largo de todo el escenario quitando
personas de mi camino hasta que llegué
con él su nombre ron white
y por primera vez conocí a los atletas
mentales esas personas
que entrenan todo el tiempo su capacidad
de retención y de memorización y que
cree que nos dijo algo muy parecido a lo
siguiente hay hatton average memory niño
tengo una memoria promedio y también
olvido las cosas como tú pero hoy he
aprendido a recordar cualquier cosa
porque la utilizo todos los días
y si llama papá se va a parecer que va a
ser así de fácil después de ver todo lo
que acaba de hacer me hizo quedar como
un simple mortal de un don ariel a su
lado no le creía al principio pero me
inspiró me influyó bastante a saber un
poquito más del tema y fue mi casa me
dediqué varios meses como rata de
laboratorio y a investigar todos lo que
encontré en memoria y hacerme pruebas a
mí mismo a ver si era cierto hasta que
un día dije era totalmente cierto
descubrí tres cosas la mala la mala
memoria no existe la memoria no es un
músculo y la memoria fotográfica es un
mito tampoco existen interesantes
significa que creer lo contrario nos
limita
desde ahí me convertí también en un
atleta mental escribir tres libros al
respecto y después de eso puede crear un
método para poder recordar todo lo que a
mí me importaba y vi que funcionaba y
ahora era momentos y me sirvió a mí qué
tal que le sirve a otras personas no
estaría nada mal y me involucre varios
años
a ayudarle a muchas personas como a más
de 700 niños estudiantes adultos a tener
una mejor memoria hasta que vi que
funcionaba funcionaba y es justo lo que
voy a compartir con ustedes el día de
hoy desde este momento voy a empezar a
mostrar información muy técnica y
sofisticada acerca de la memoria humana
saleh descubrí un patrón muy interesante
muy curioso acerca de la memoria todos
nacemos con una memoria pura e inocente
capaz de recordar cualquier cosa cuando
más lo necesitas de una manera muy
organizada pero tiene un detalle que
conforme pasa el tiempo se transforma en
uno de los tres tipos de memoria que más
padecemos las personas cuales son
primero están las personas con la
memoria tipo bullying es a qué le dices
oye memoria no me acuerdo que es justo
lo que iba a hacer y el dinero no yo
tampoco sé no me metas en esto a ver
cómo le haces
y si todavía las cosas porque sientes
que todo el tiempo conspira en tu contra
después viene en la memoria tipo touring
esa que le dices oye conoces a una
persona en menos de dos segundos se te
olvida su nombre le dice es como te
llamabas
éstas se volvían dos cosas índices que
tendrían las cosas y dejas tus lentes
aquí arriba en la cabeza
y por último viene la persona con la
memoria tipo triángulo de las bermudas
donde la leyenda dice
una vez que la información entra jamás
vuelve a salir
como mi carrera universitaria en ese
entonces y eso hace que nuestra vida
gira en torno a tres frases que es lo
que iba a hacer qué es lo que te iba a
decir y no me acuerdo todo el tiempo
esto sucede porque esta memoria pura e
inocente tiene un enemigo que la molesta
todos los días si no la puedes controlar
se llama el borrador crónico de los
recuerdos
este sujeto solo tiene un trabajo borrar
todo lo que es irrelevante en tu vida
para que no te satures pero tiene un
detalle tiene una obsesión compulsiva
por borrar todo lo que se encuentra a su
paso incluyendo todo lo que te importa y
llega a restringir tu memoria todos los
días para que se te olviden tus objetos
personales les explica ese botón de
olvidé mi contraseña
se te queda en la punta de la lengua
justo lo que iba a decir incluso hace
que olvides lo que yo olvidaste
para que no lo puedas molestar porque no
cuál es la clave que no elimine todo
aquello que te importa y te hace a ti
como persona
que pudieran hacer un cambio físico en
tu cuerpo y sigue siendo tú
pero si te quitan la memoria
dejarías de ser quien tú eres
pienso un solo día en tu vida sin
memoria que te levantarás de tu cama te
miras al espejo y dijeras quién está ahí
que no supieras en qué momento de la
historia te encuentras creas tus
fotografías si no supieras quiénes están
ahí y que todo aquello que jamás
no tuviera ningún sentido en tu vida
qué pasaría si te dijera que si es cómo
vives todos los días
como si no tuvieras memoria
vivimos en una época de excesos de
información en una crisis de memoria en
donde delegamos nuestros recuerdos a
otras cosas para que los recuerden por
nosotros haciendo la floja es decir hace
más de 2000 años la gente lo sabía todo
y la erudición y la inteligencia depende
de qué tanto podías recordar ahora casi
casi depende en donde puedes encontrar
lo que ya olvidaste es decir recuerdas a
tus amigos gracias a facebook recuerda
sus nombres los números de teléfono
gracias a un celular recuerdas a dónde
llegar gracias a un gps lo que olvidaste
en la escuela gracias a google que con
un clic de lo recuerda incluso
necesitamos de notitas notificaciones y
recordatorios para saber qué es lo que
tenemos que hacer entonces en tu memoria
se vuelve dependiente
pregúntate en qué está siendo
dependiente tu memoria ahorita no le
entregas tu vida a ese borrador a ese
sujeto que sólo se aprovecha en las
situaciones donde menos atento estás
porque la memoria no existe en
situaciones donde no existe la atención
porque atención es igual a retención
pero tiene un punto débil ese borrador
de recuerdos se los voy a decir su punto
débil es que no puede eliminar todas
aquellas memorias que tengan el
pegamento de los recuerdos
qué hacer tus memorias tan sólidas que
no las puedas olvidar y que aquel
borrador no funcione pero aquí lo
interesante es que todos aquí presentes
estoy seguro que utilizan ese pegamento
sin que se den cuenta es decir si en
este momento por aquí atrás entrará un
toro y yo tuviera que correr por mi vida
en su vida olvidaría lo que pasó
entiende que se despuebla te acuerdas
del toro que hizo que se salir el loco
de la memoria
y así como es se tienen muchos otros
recuerdos con ese pegamento algo que los
marca el punto es que puedan utilizar
ese pegamento a su favor y yo los voy a
acompañar y para que empiecen a
activarlo todos van a acompañarme
poniendo sus dedos
de esta manera en frente de ustedes
ok
van a apuntar rápidamente a sus pies ahí
van a ver cómo salen unos tenis para
correr listos ahora las rodillas ahí van
a ver cómo sale una almohada muy suave
para que se van a dormir
listo cadera aquí van a imaginar como
hay un cinturón lleno de vitaminas
listo
se van al estómago al pecho aquí va a
haber un monje que está meditando y
quién sabe cómo llegó ahí
ahora el brazo derecho ahí van a
imaginar que tienen una espada wifi acá
es más todos hagan así
ahora el brazo izquierdo aquí van a
imaginar que tienen sus mejores amigos
sentados en ustedes y por último su
cabeza todos van a ver ahí están ustedes
enseñando lo que saben
visto de esta manera su memoria tiene
pegamento lo que acaban de hacer es
grabarse y recordar cuáles son los 7
hábitos para que su memoria funcione
todos los días pero cuáles son y todos
no van a ayudar a recordarlos en voz
alta sale que había en los pies
porque hacer ejercicio fortalece las
neuronas que habían las rodillas
porque dormir adecuadamente consolida la
memoria que había en la cintura
vitaminas porque eso nutre a tu cerebro
que había en el pecho en el estómago por
qué meditar entrena la atención y
atención es igual a retención que viene
el brazo derecho porque debes desafiar a
tu mente todos los días que alguien el
brazo izquierdo
porque debes relacionarte con gente
positiva y por último que en la cabeza
ustedes enseñando lo que saben porque si
enseñan y comparten lo que saben lo
aprenden del doble y esta manera ya
tienen pegamento de una manera muy
sencilla el punto es que ahora ustedes
lo pueden activar cuando ustedes quieran
y recordar lo que les importa y para
ello necesitan cumplir con 4 muy
sencillos elementos con el poder de su
atención cuáles son
todos nos van a acompañar a activar
estos cuatro elementos van a poner sus
palmas de sus manos en frente de ustedes
y lo único que van a hacer vas a ser
imitar mis movimientos solo invitarme a
ver tengo que sentir con emoción lo que
quiero recordar visualizar lo que quiero
recordar imaginar lo que quiero recordar
y así conectarlo con mi memoria perfecto
es decir si utilizan la emoción
visualizan la información crean imágenes
todo el tiempo acerca de ella y lo
conectan en su memoria con lugares ya
conocidos
para poder utilizar ese pegamento en
cualquier momento en su vida y recordar
todo aquello que les importa
porque tú eres el cúmulo de tus
recuerdos
de tus recuerdos te hacen a ti la
calidad de tu vida al final depende de
cómo las recuerdes
entonces enfocarte en recuerda todo lo
que es importante olvidar es
completamente normal no tiene nada de
malo pero si olvida y entrega y delega a
tu celular oa otras cosas todo aquello
que es irrelevante en tu vida que te
pueda perturbar pero nunca te atrevas a
delegar y entregar todo aquello que
puede ser recordado por ti mismo o por
ti misma con el poder de tu memoria haz
de tu memoria una experiencia digna de
ser recordada y mi objetivo el día de
hoy era probarles que todos aquí
presentes ya tienen pegamento y que su
memoria es excepcional y para que lo ve
lo vean los voy a acompañar para que ese
borrador de recuerdos no elimine todo lo
que acabas de aprender hoy
si se dieron cuenta al principio de
esta charla creamos una serie de
recuerdos en su gran memoria o en este
lugar y todos me van a ayudar a recordar
que había en cada lugar en voz alta
listos perfecto que había en la puerta
muy bien que había las sillas que había
en los arcos
que había en
la pantalla que había él
en las luces muy bien un diario que
había en
y que había en el escenario
perfecto lo que acaban de hacer es
recordar 17 ideas centrales para que se
los puedan llevar y aplicarlas en sus
vidas pero cuáles son rápidamente
debes enfocarte a recordar lo que es
importante en tu vida
la memoria es una habilidad que
cualquier persona puede desarrollar
debes evitar el borrador de recuerdos a
toda costa debes de poner mucha atención
porque atención es igual a la pretensión
debes utilizar el pegamento de los
recuerdos a través de emoción
visualización imaginación y conexión el
diario representa que tú eres el cúmulo
de los recuerdos y ellos te hacen a ti y
por último el cuerpo humano representa
los siete hábitos para que tu memoria
funcione todos los días y de esta forma
acaban de recordar su charla completa
ahora necesito
que me confiesen una cosa más
quien recuerda lo que acaba de aprender
justo ahora
perfecto
para ponerle pegamento a tu memoria
[Aplausos]
[Música]